Prof: At the end last
time we asked the question
whether molecular mechanics
programs are useful?
And the answer is yes;
in fact, they're really
nowadays indispensable for
evaluating the energy of
molecules and their shapes.
But are they true?
Are they really fundamentally
correct, the same way we believe
quantum mechanics to be
fundamentally correct?
And the answer to that is
certainly no.
We already saw how they depend
on so many arbitrary parameters
that are just adjusted to try to
fit data from some molecules.
And then there's the hope that
they'll fit other molecules,
and sometimes they do and
sometimes they don't.
They usually do pretty well,
but there can be special cases
that differ for some reason,
and it's hard to predict those
ahead of time.
So one has to look at them with
a certain grain of salt.
Okay?
A good example of where they're
demonstrably incorrect is in the
question of van der Waals radii;
for example,
the contact between two bromine
atoms that are not bonded to one
another.
So we're going to make a plot
showing a bromine attached to
carbon,
and we're going to do this in
the same spirit that Dunitz and
his crew looked at amines
attacking carbonyls.
We're going to look at many,
many crystal structures,
and we're going to have --
we're going to rotate the
various structures so that they
have a C-Br bond that lines up
right there.
And then we're going to see how
far it is to the nearest
neighboring bromine,
from some other molecule.
Okay?
And now what would we expect?
Well there's a certain van der
Waals radius for bromine.
So the next neighbor should
have its bromine in contact with
that one.
So we should go that radius
again, to get to a neighbor.
And there should be various
directions,
of course, where the neighbor
could be,
but always at that same
distance, if they're in contact
with one another.
Okay?
So there should be an arc of a
circle, like that.
So if we make these -- if we
rotate these various crystal
structures that have been
determined,
so the C and Br line up there,
and the other Br lies in the
plane --
the neighboring Br from another
molecule --
then the closest they should
get is along that dashed red
line.
Now, of course,
there could be others that are
further away,
that aren't in contact.
And in fact there could be some
that are a little bit closer.
You'd really expect some to be
a little bit closer.
Because there's van der Waals
attraction, out to infinite
distance;
at least to great -- to
substantial distance,
much further than where they're
actually in contact.
They're attracting one another.
So this bromine is part of a
molecule that has many atoms in
it, and the other bromine is
part of a molecule that has many
atoms.
And all these other atoms are
attracting one another,
pulling toward one another.
Now, of course,
it would just collapse,
except for the fact that the
ones, the closest ones,
run into one another.
But that means that they should
get slightly closer than just
precise contact,
because they're being pushed
together by all the other atoms
in those molecules.
So we would expect neighbors to
be slightly closer;
some of the neighbors,
at least, to be slightly closer
than this van der Waals radius,
or double the van der Waals
radius;
whatever the van der Waals
radius means.
Right?
The question is where you get
that.
But, at any rate,
we could -- you can look up in
a book and see what they say the
van der Waals radius of bromine
is, and make a plot like this.
And then you'll put points on
it, for all the different
crystal structures of where
neighboring bromines are.
And they look like this.
Here's what I just said:
To balance attractive and
repulsive forces between
neighbors, the closest atoms
must be a little bit too close.
Okay?
And here's what you see.
And indeed, some of the atoms,
in some of the cases,
are a little bit too close.
And, of course,
many are further because other
atoms are running into one
another, of these two molecules.
Okay?
Well what do you find
particularly curious about this
plot?
Anything?
Chenyu?
Student:  It's not
really circular.
Prof: I can't hear very
well.
Student:  It's not
really circular.
Prof: It's not circular.
It's an ellipse. Right?
There are many more inside the
red dashed line at the top than
out to the side.
So what do you infer from that,
about the shape of the bromine
atom?
Student:  It's not
spherical.
Prof: It's not
Right?
Okay.
So the bromine atoms seem not
to be spherical.
Right?
But every molecular mechanics
program calculates van der Waals
interactions between atoms as if
they are spherical.
The interaction depends only on
the distance,
not on the direction.
Right?
So clearly molecular mechanics
programs are not perfect.
Right?
But still they're pretty good,
and you can get interesting
information out of them -- from
them.
Plus, they can tell you
something about
why something
might be the way it is -- right?
-- torsional energy and things
like that.
Okay, and in fact if you're
trying to deal with a big
molecule, it's hopeless to do
quantum mechanics on it.
So here's angiostatin,
which is an anti-cancer drug.
And this is the largest -- at
least as of a couple of years
ago;
I suspect it's still the case
-- this is the largest molecule
whose shape has been optimized
by quantum mechanics.
Right?
And not a really high level of
quantum mechanics.
Here's a description of it from
Mike Frisch, from Gaussian
Incorporated in 2003.
He said: "We optimized
Kringle 1"
(which is this thing;
I don't know why you call it
Kringle 1) "with the AM1
method" (which is a very
low-level of quantum mechanics)
"using Gaussian 03.
Plasminogen Kringle 1 contains
1200 atoms, which are made up of
642 non-hydrogen atoms and 578
hydrogen atoms.
The job takes about 650
optimization steps,
starting from the molecular
mechanics geometry."
So first they used molecular
mechanics to get the approximate
structure,
and then they started adjusting
it with quantum mechanics,
step by step,
until after 650 steps they got
to a minimum of energy,
and that's this energy.
But obviously this is not an
everyday occurrence,
to do something like this.
So if you're dealing with a big
biological molecule,
you have to use molecular
mechanics.
Right?
But you know that fundamentally
it's not right.
It may get a lot of things
right, but don't believe that it
came down from Sinai on the
tablets.
Right?
Yes Lucas?
Student:  How long did
it take to do just one
calculation?
Prof: I don't know.
We could ask him sometime.
He's around here from time to
time.
I haven't set him up to come in.
Okay.
So quantum mechanics is pretty
close, as we believe,
to the truth.
Molecular mechanics isn't close
to the truth but for practical
purposes it's indispensable.
Now, we wonder whether the
standard structural model of
molecules that we have is
realistic in its geometric
detail;
things about bonds,
bond lengths,
bond angles and so on.
And how are we going to know
whether it is?
We're going to use X-ray
diffraction to see just how
regular bond distances are.
Okay, now we're helped in this
by what's called the Cambridge
Structural Database.
In Cambridge,
in England, there's this
building where people sit and
collect X-ray structure data
from all over the world,
and make it computer-searchable
and so on,
so that you can look at many,
many structures.
And you see that many
structures are available.
This is how many structures
there are, as of any particular
year, in the Cambridge
Structural Database.
And you see it's up to about
half a million X-ray structures
have been determined,
and put in the Cambridge
Database, as of now.
You can click on there and go
to the website to see it,
if you want;
it's interesting.
Okay, and they predict that
there'll be half a million by
2010.
Okay, now how many atoms are
there -- this is how many
structures -- how many atoms are
there?
How many bonds in each
structure?
Well, as time goes on,
X-ray is able to do more and
more complicated molecules.
So that at the beginning there
were only about an average of
twenty-seven atoms in a
structure,
but by 1982 there were
forty-four, and by 1990 there
were fifty-four,
and after 2002,
or something like that,
there were seventy-three.
So the molecules are getting
bigger and bigger.
And, as of now,
as of at least this last
January,
the last issue of the database,
there were thirty and a half
million atom positions,
x,y,z
coordinates, available.
Right?
And, of course,
there are many more bonds than
there are atoms,
because most atoms form several
bonds.
So there are greater than forty
million bond distances
available.
Now the question is,
how regular are they?
Do carbon-carbon bond distances
tend to be the same?
Well in 1987,
when the Cambridge Database was
much smaller than it is now,
it was already large enough to
do pretty good statistics on
this thing.
And here's a paper published in
that year,
that you could look at if you
want to,
by people from the
Crystallographic Data Center in
Cambridge,
that talked about this subject.
Now here's a table that shows
how many different kinds of
bonds they divided the
experimental data into,
so that within any given type
the bonds would all be about the
same length.
Right?
It's not surprising that
different types of bonds have
different lengths.
But if you subdivide -- like
double bonds and single bonds
will be different lengths.
Right?
So those would be at least two
types.
But notice how many types they
used.
So, for example,
there are 119 different types
of carbon-oxygen bonds,
that they did statistics on;
not bonds but types of bonds.
Okay?
Now here are those 119
different types.
There are sixty types that are
made up of an sp^3 carbon
bonding to an O of type two.
And there are seventeen types
of bonds, which have sp^2
carbon bonded to that type of
carbon.
O2 means the oxygen has bonded
to two different atoms;
O1 it's bonded to just one
atom.
Right?
There are four types where it's
an aromatic carbon that's bonded
to a divalent oxygen,
and there are thirty-eight
where an sp^2 carbon is
bonded to an oxygen that makes
bonds to only one carbon;
that is, a C-O double bond.
So there are thirty-eight
different types of C-O double
bonds.
Okay?
Or, in the case of C-N,
there are ninety-seven
different types of C-N bonds in
their tabulation.
And for carbon there are 175
different types of carbon-carbon
bonds.
And notice that there are
twenty-seven different types of
carbon-carbon bonds where both
the carbons are sp^3 hybridized.
Right?
So they're dividing this into
lots and lots of different
categories, in order to get
regularity within each category.
Now let's look here at those
twenty-seven different kinds of
bonds that are carbon
sp^3 to carbon
sp^3.
Okay, so for each type is given
the mean and the median -- two
kinds of average of the bond
distance;
what the standard deviation is;
what the distance is that
splits off the shortest
one-fourth, and the longest
one-fourth;
and then how many different
examples there were to do this,
to make the statistics on.
Okay so now,
in this table,
C with a pound sign means any
sp^3 carbon.
So at the top there we see a
CH_3 bonded to CH_2.
So that's the bond distance
we're interested in;
methyl to CH_2.
But that CH_2 has some other
sp^3 carbon on it.
Right?
So that's one type of bond.
And you notice the mean
distance is 1.513.
And if there are two sp^3
carbons on the second
carbon, then it's 1.524 average.
And if there are three of them,
it's 1.534.
Now notice the standard
deviation is about 1% of the
bond distance.
So within that class they're
all within about + or - 1%.
Right?
So a very small deviation.
So they wanted to get them --
they wanted to make the classes
restricted enough that you'd
have a predictable bond distance
-- right?
-- within 1%.
Okay, notice that crowding
seems to stretch the bond.
As you put more carbons on that
second carbon,
which is bonded to methyl,
the bond to methyl gets longer
and longer;
longer by a little less than
1%, as you put more crowding on
the second carbon.
Here's a graph of it,
of that, the standard deviation
and the mean.
Right?
So you see it gets,
as you go from one R to two R's
to three R's on the second
carbon, the bond gets a little
longer and a little longer;
although they can overlap. Okay?
Now then we go down to here,
where both carbons are
substituted.
So the first carbon has two or
three carbons on it,
and the second carbon also has
two or three carbons on it.
And now you see there's still
more crowding.
They get longer and longer.
And, in fact,
when you have three other
carbons on each of the carbons
whose bond you're interested in,
then those others repel one
another,
by van der Waals repulsion,
and it gets actually pretty
long.
Right?
It gets almost 10% -- well 7%
longer, or something like that.
So anyhow, you can get these
kinds of regularities,
based on the statistics.
And if you wanted just an
overall average carbon-carbon
bond distance,
it's about 1.53 angstroms.
Okay?
However, if you have
cyclopropane,
or cyclobutane,
then the bonds are,
in the case of cyclopropane,
unusually short,
1.51;
and in the case of cyclobutane,
unusually long,
1.55.
Okay?
Now if you have sp^3-
sp^2, as a carbon-carbon
bond, rather than
sp^3- sp^3,
then what would you expect?
Would you expect a shorter bond
or a longer bond,
if one of them is sp^2?
Just guess.
Student:  Repeat the
question.
Prof: sp^2 means
you'll get better overlap,
stronger bond;
probably a shorter bond. Right?
Just a little review for you
here.
Okay?
And indeed, 1.50 is the average.
So there are hundreds and
hundreds of these,
as you can see,
in this particular paper.
But if you want just
order-of-magnitude things --
actually it's better than
order-of-magnitude.
But for carbon-carbon single
bonds, it's about 1.53
angstroms.
For double bonds, 1.32.
For triple bonds, 1.18.
And for aromatic bonds,
say within a benzene ring,
these are one-and-a-half bonds.
So not surprisingly they come
between single and double.
Okay?
Notice they're a little closer
to double than they are to
single;
1.38 to 1.32,
as opposed to 1.38 versus 1.53.
Does it surprise you that
they're a little closer to
double than single?
Notice, even if they were
single bonds,
but between carbons that were
part of aromatic rings,
they would be sp^2-
sp^2 carbon-carbon bonds.
And we've already seen that
those would be unusually short.
Right?
So you don't expect it to be
one-and-a-half,
the average between a normal
single and a normal double,
if you think about it with a
little more sophistication.
Okay, and then as we see here,
a single, if it's
sp^3- sp^2,
is 1.5;
and a single,
if it's sp^2-
sp^2, is 1.46.
So the 1.38 is closer to being
halfway between 1.46 and 1.32,
than it is between 1.53 and
1.32.
So depending on how accurate
your model needs to be,
you can get pretty good
guesses, based on values you
would find in a table.
Now you can see some
interesting departures from
regularity.
Here I'll show it in aromatic
carbon-to-nitrogen bonds.
So there's an aniline
derivative.
Aniline is aminobenzene.
Okay, so there's -- that red
bond is the bond we're talking
about, and there's the
distribution,
a histogram,
of distances.
What's funny about the
histogram?
Dana?
Student:  There's one
that's suddenly low.
Prof: There's a hole in
the middle.
Right?
It's bimodal. Right?
So it looks like there are two
different kinds of bonds between
nitrogen and aromatic carbon.
Now let's split them out,
the ones that are in one and
the ones that are in the other,
and see why they have this
difference.
It turns out that if you do
ones where the nitrogen and the
benzene are co-planar,
as shown above,
then you have one nice
histogram.
And if the nitrogen is
pyramidal, rather than being
planar, then it's another
histogram.
So it depends on whether the
nitrogen is planar or pyramidal.
But when the nitrogen is
planar, it's co-planar with the
benzene.
And for good reason.
It's so that the unshared pair
on the nitrogen can be
delocalized into vacant
orbitals, π orbitals
of the benzene ring.
So that makes this
carbon-to-nitrogen bond a little
bit double bond-like,
and shortens it.
Whereas if the nitrogen is
twisted,
compared to the benzene,
then there's no reason for it
to be flat,
to have a p orbital that
will overlap with the benzene
orbitals.
So it becomes pyramidal.
But more importantly,
there's no double-bond
character anymore,
to the carbon-nitrogen bond.
So the bonds are longer than
the ones that are partial double
bonds.
So that's why it's bimodal.
So you learn something from
these statistical analyses.
You have poor π
overlap when the nitrogen-carbon
bond is twisted.
Now, how complex must a model
be in order to predict useful
structures?
So from the point of view of
the Cambridge compilers,
they wanted to get standard
deviations and bond distance of
about 1%, as you saw from the
table.
And in order to do this,
as you saw, they needed 175
different kinds of C-C bonds,
differing in these various
ways, as we've illustrated;
and 97 different types of C-N
and 119 different types of C-O
bonds.
And 682 different kinds of
bonds altogether,
in their tabulation.
Okay, now we have ambitious
goals.
We want to understand all stuff;
chemicals that is. Okay?
We wonder how things behave --
their properties -- and their
chemical transformations as
well.
Right?
And the key to doing this,
the trick we're going to use,
is to understand the basis of
structure -- how the atoms are
arranged -- and energy.
And we want to do this in terms
of bonds.
You could do it entirely
without bonds;
just use quantum mechanics to
minimize energies of atoms,
of arrangements of atoms,
and calculate those energies.
And you'd have that same
information, structure and
energy, but you wouldn't
understand anything,
you couldn't predict anything
in your head.
With bonds, you have a tool
that will allow you to predict
things.
Okay, so let's just see how
well bonds do.
Obviously there are going to be
corrections, having to do with
conformation and strain,
as we've been talking about.
But is there an underlying
energy for a given composition,
or a given constitution,
a given set of bonds?
Can you predict energy as well
as structure?
In other words,
how standard are bond energies?
If we're going to do our
understanding in terms of bonds,
can you add up energies for all
the bonds and get the overall
energy for the molecule?
Knowing, of course,
that there are going to be
corrections for strain and so
on.
Okay, so this started in 1868
already.
In the very first issue,
the second paper of the first
issue of the German chemical
journal,
Chemische
Berichte,
which was the journal of the
Chemical Society of Berlin,
the second paper ever in that
journal,
was "On the Regularity and
Calculation of Heat of
Combustion of Organic
Compounds."
So Hermann was interested in
this because he was a
physiologist and he wanted to
know how much energy you get out
of the food you burn up in your
body.
Right?
So could you predict,
on the basis of what substances
you eat, how much energy could
be available?
Okay?
So physiology led him to study
this.
And there was another paper,
very shortly after that,
in the same journal,
by Oppenheim,
"On the Relationship of
Heat of Combustion with the
Constitution of
Substances."
Right?
So could you look at the
constitution?
He didn't mean it yet,
constitution.
Notice this is 1868;
still pretty early days.
He didn't mean constitution to
mean nature and sequence of
bonds.
He just meant what was in there.
Okay, so how did they try to do
this?
Could we do it,
the way they did it,
by predicting the heat of
combustion,
how much heat you get out of
burning a thing,
say just by how much carbon and
hydrogen?
We know you can burn carbon,
coal, and get a certain amount
of heat out.
We know you can burn hydrogen
gas and get a certain amount of
heat out.
Could you take a substance,
know how much carbon and how
much hydrogen is in it,
and predict how much heat
you'll get out of burning it?
Right?
It would be great if that were
true.
Okay?
So let's see how well it works.
So you're going to compare,
to graphite -- that's carbon --
and hydrogen.
Right?
So we'd have a certain number
of atoms per mole,
and then we know what the heat
of combustion is,
per mole.
You get 94r kilocalories out of
burning a mole of graphite,
a mole of carbon in graphite.
You get 57.8 out of burning
hydrogen.
Okay?
That's per -- I'm not sure,
we'll have to see,
I think that's per atom,
not per molecule;
we'll see.
Yeah, no, it's per H_2. Okay.
So it's 94.05 per carbon,
and 57.8 per H_2.
Okay?
Now you take some other
substance, like ethene,
C_2H_4.
Right?
So you should get two times
94.05, for the carbon,
and two times 57.8;
because it's 57.8 for every two
hydrogens.
You've got four hydrogens.
So two times that.
So you should get 303.7 out of
burning a mole of ethene.
Right?
In fact, you get 316. Right?
Which isn't bad.
It's an error of 12
kilocalories/mol,
but that's only 4%.
So you're pretty close already
in predicting that.
Now so we can be optimistic.
Well let's try something else.
Notice, we could even
understand why you get a little
more heat out than you expected,
because one of the bonds in
C_2H_4 is not such a strong
bond.
Right?
The second bond of the double
bond isn't so strong.
So you expect the starting
material not to be as stable as
it might have been.
It's a little higher in energy
than it would've been if that
second bond was really good.
So when you burn it,
you get more heat out,
because there was more in it to
begin with.
Right?
It was less stable to begin
with.
So we can understand that.
Now let's try to extend it to
other things.
How about cyclohexane?
There we have 6 carbons and 12
hydrogens.
You'd predict 911.
It turns out to be 881.
It's off by 29.
But that's only a 3% error.
Right?
Not bad, we're doing well.
Now how about cyclohexanol.
Right?
There again it has -- since it
has the same amount -- you don't
expect to get anything out of
oxygen, because you don't
oxidize oxygen -- right?
-- in burning.
It's only the carbon and
hydrogen that you oxidize.
So you predict exactly the
same, 911;
it's the same amount of
hydrogen and carbon.
But you only get out 842,
instead of 881.
So now you're off by 68
kilocalories/mol,
or 8%.
And if you take sugar,
which is again C_6H_12,
but O_6 now,
now you get out only 670.
You're off by 240.
So you're making a 36% error.
Now it's getting pretty bad.
Right?
Does that surprise you,
that when there's oxygen in the
molecule you get less out by
burning;
less heat out by burning,
when there's already oxygen
there?
What is burning?
Student:  Oxidation.
Prof: What do you do?
Prof: You're oxidizing
it.
These are already partly
oxidized, if they have oxygen in
them.
So you've already gone partway.
You don't expect to get so much
out anymore.
Right?
Okay, so that makes sense.
They're partially pre-oxidized.
So you make bigger -- you make
errors in this.
So for fuel purposes,
for physiology,
this isn't so bad;
especially if you could include
some kind of correction for
every oxygen that's already
there, partway to the product.
Then you'd get numbers that --
you know, within 5,
maybe 10% -- are going to be
right.
So you actually could add up
the -- just from the composition
-- add up what atoms are there
and predict how much heat you
can get out by burning.
Right?
Now, but might you need a more
complex model,
if what your goal is,
is to predict chemically useful
energies,
rather than just ones that say
how much energy you're going to
get by burning your chocolate
bar or whatever?
Okay?
For physiology purposes,
you might be content with plus
or minus 5%.
But for predicting the
equilibrium constant between
cyclohexane and cyclohexanol --
suppose there was some
reaction, oxidation reaction,
where you can convert one to
the other,
and you're going to be off by
1% say,
which would be 9
kilocalories/mol.
So you're off by 1%.
How off would you be in the
equilibrium constant?
How big a factor in equilibrium
would nine kilocalories be?
Do you remember how to do that?
How do you go from energy to
equilibrium constant?
I'm going to keep boring in on
this until you remember it,
because it's certainly going to
be on the exam.
Katherine?
Student:  Ten to the --
you do the three quarters.
Prof: 10^3/4ths of that.
Okay, so 3/4ths of nine is
about seven.
Right?
So by what factor would you be
off in predicting an equilibrium
constant, if you were off by 9
kilocalories/mol?
Student:  10^-7th.
Prof: 10^7th. Right?
Is that good enough,
to be off by ten-million-fold?
Not very good. Right?
So you're off by 10^7th.
So a useful model clearly has
to go, to get better numbers
than you can get just from the
composition, just from what
atoms are there.
You're going to have to
consider bonds --
and that's what I said we were
going to do --
to see how good it can be if
you just have certain energies
for certain bonds.
So we need to go to
constitution.
So now when we're going to talk
about energy,
there's going to be a big,
a really fundamental question.
So here's cyclohexane.
It has a certain energy.
What number should I put on it?
Should I say it's 13,28,
562 million?
Right?
The question is one of our
fundamental questions.
What's that?
Students:
Compared to what?
Prof: Compared to what?
What are we going to call zero?
Okay?
Now for practical purposes of
doing an experiment,
there's a very good reference.
and it's the one we've just
been using, without saying so --
which is CO_2 and H_2O;
the same amount of carbon in
CO_2 and the same amount of
hydrogen in H_2O.
Right?
Why is that a convenient
reference point to take,
from an experimental point of
view?
Lucas?
Student:  Well that's
what you get in burning.
Prof: Ah,
so all you have to do is burn
it, see how much heat you get
out,
and you know the energy
relative to CO_2 and H_2O.
So that's called the heat of
combustion.
And it turns out to be 881.6
kilocalories/mol,
for cyclohexane.
We were just talking about
that.
Okay?
Now so it's easily measured.
That's a good comparison.
But if I hadn't told you that
we wanted an experimental
comparison,
that we wanted sort of a
simple-to-think-about comparison
--
maybe if you couldn't even
measure it --
what might you think of as a
point of comparison?
If you're going to talk about
-- you got a whole bunch of
different compounds,
you want to know how stable is,
compared to what?
What are we going to use as the
what?
Student: Unbonded atoms.
Prof: One -- it could be
unbonded atoms.
That would be a really good
one, because then when we start
with atoms,
we put them together and make
bonds,
and if there's a certain energy
for each bond,
then we would be comparing our
molecule,
or our model of a molecule,
with all these bonds,
to the atoms.
That'd be a very good one.
But that's going to be a very
hard one to deal with
experimentally -- right?
-- to go to atoms.
There's another thing that you
could actually have in a bottle,
that might make sense to
compare to,
and that would be the elements,
in their standard state.
So graphite;
how stable is it compared to
graphite being the carbon and
H_2 gas being the hydrogen?
Right?
So that, if you're comparing to
the elements in their standard
states,
that difference -- notice that
cyclohexane is just slightly
more stable than the elements
bonded to one another.
Right?
And that's called the
"heat of formation".
That's just a definition;
that's what the heat of
formation is.
It's the energy compared to the
elements in their standard
state.
Okay?
Now, but how could you measure
that experimentally?
How would you get heat of
formation?
You know the energy of
cyclohexane relative to CO_2 and
H_2O, by doing combustion.
How would you know it relative
to graphite and hydrogen?
You can't mix hydrogen and
graphite and have it suddenly
magically become cyclohexane and
measure the heat involved in
that transformation.
But how could you get it?
Do you see?
Student:
>.
Prof: There's a neat
trick to use.
Student: Burning
graphite and hydrogen.
Prof: Ah,
you could burn the graphite and
the hydrogen,
see how much heat they give
off, and then take the
difference.
Right?
So that's what you do.
You burn that and get 911.1,
and the difference then,
29.5, is the heat of formation
of cyclohexane,
from the elements.
Well done.
Okay, but Andrew says it would
be great,
for purposes of -- oh and in
fact these heats of formation
are available in tables for lots
and lots of compounds.
And this brings up a question.
This table is taken -- and
there are several others here
for alkanes, cycloalkanes,
alkenes, alkynes,
aromatic hydrocarbons and
everything.
You can look these up.
You can find them on the Web
too, all these heats of
formation.
So it's how stable a particular
substance is.
And it's not just molecules.
Notice they also have atoms and
radicals, inorganic compounds,
cations, and anions;
all of them relative to the
elements.
So you can find tables like
this.
These particular tables I took
from a book by Streitwieser,
Heathcock and Kosower,
which we've often used as a
textbook in the course.
I think it might be out of
print now, though the publisher
may still have some copies.
But would you like to have a
textbook for second semester,
so we don't have to continue
with the Wiki stuff?
Students:  Yes.
Prof: Now,
so if we're going to do that,
we have to make the decision.
Are we going to get a slick,
new book, that has a lot of
nice color pictures in it and so
on, and the very latest thing?
Or are we going to get
something like Streitwieser and
Heathcock?
Which I think is a wonderful
book, but you're going to have
find secondhand copies,
or maybe the publisher still
has a few and so on.
These new books,
they charge an absolute arm and
a leg for them,
as you probably have found out.
So I want to do it however you
want to do it.
Actually, why don't you think
about it a little bit?
I like this book,
but there are plenty of other
books that are just fine for our
purposes.
And we won't be 100% in the
book, you won't be surprised to
hear.
But there'll be a lot of stuff
that could be useful in having a
textbook.
Chenyu?
Student:  Could you tell
us the level of clarity or
quality in instruction,
clarity
>.
Prof: It's not going to
make a lot of difference.
In fact, we could probably get
one of these,
you know, outlines of organic
chemistry,
little paperback books and so
on, that would probably have the
stuff we wanted.
But then you probably couldn't
hold your head up against your
roommates, and so on,
if you have a little dinky book
like that.
>
When I took organic chemistry,
the professor was Professor
Fieser,
who wrote lots and lots of
textbooks,
and he had just written one for
nurses,
for a one-semester course.
So we took two semesters and
used a book that was about that
thick.
It was -- I wasn't too
embarrassed, I didn't know
enough to be embarrassed at that
time.
And it was a good book.
I don't have it anymore.
Somebody borrowed it from me
and didn't give it back.
It was a neat book.
But anyhow, we can talk about
this a little more next time.
But think over whether you want
to fork out for a shiny new
book,
or would rather have a book,
which I think is equal in
quality,
maybe better even,
that you'd have to go buy
secondhand copies or something,
but it'd save you some money.
So think about it,
and we'll talk about it next
time.
Okay, and anyhow,
that's where I got this table.
Now, let's look at the heat of
formation, from this book,
of cycloalkanes.
And so cycloalkanes are CH_2
groups in a ring.
Right?
Six CH_2 groups is cyclohexane.
Two CH_2 groups is cycloethane,
or ethylene.
Right?
So now here's the heat of
formation there;
how big the ring is -- two
carbons, 3 carbons,
4 carbons and so on -- and what
the heat of formation is.
Now let's try to make sense out
of this.
We could look at the heat of
formation, divided by how many
carbon or CH_2 units there are
in there.
It could be they'd all be the
same.
That would be the simplest
thing, if all we had to do is
take how many CH_2 groups there
were there,
add that up,
and we would get what the
stability is.
And it's -- they're not too bad.
But again, compared to what?
Right?
So you're going to be -- the
biggest error is 6,
that I see there,
and a more typical error is
about 4 say, or something like
that.
So 4 -- that would be,
if you were off by 4
kilocalories/mol -- ah,
but it's per CH_2 group.
Ah, so it gets worse, right?
If you have a lot of CH_2
groups, there's a lot of energy.
So if it were only CH_2 group,
you'd off only by a factor of
1000, if you had that kind of
error.
Okay?
Well wait a second.
This isn't an error.
This is just what it is per
group.
Right?
So it's -- well let's go one
step further here.
The minimum is 4.9.
That's for cyclohexane,
our old favorite,
which isn't strained,
remember, or at least not very
strained, at least chair
cyclohexane.
Okay, so let's suppose that
that's the standard,
and everything else is a little
bit higher in energy,
more positive,
because there's some kind of
strain there.
Okay?
How big is that strain?
Well let's compare what it
would be.
So we'll call that -- you'd get
-- well say you'll get 4.9
reduced, compared to the
elements, if you have an
unstrained ring.
And now we're going to look at
the others and see how strained
they are.
Now notice, down at the bottom
here, 13,14, 15,16,
these big rings have almost
exactly the same energy.
So they're not strained. Right?
We would get a very good
prediction of what their heat of
formation is if we just multiply
from the value we got from
cyclohexane.
But the others here are a
little bit off.
So strainless theory is
n times -4.9 predicts our
heat.
So you see that we have a
strain energy,
which is the experiment,
that column shown,
versus theory;
the n times 4.9.
And here are the strain
energies you see.
Note, almost no strain energy
down at the bottom,
just a few kilocalories/mol.
That's not going to hurt us
very much.
But up at the top we have
strain -- the first one is bad,
ethylene, we know,
because the double bond isn't
so strong.
Okay, that's fine.
But then we have all single
bonds, but small ring strain,
because you don't have such
good overlap.
And we talked about that.
Okay, so 6 to 27 kilocalories
of strain there.
We already understand why that
is.
But here's an interesting one.
These ones, which are bigger
than 6 -- right?
-- bigger than 6 members in the
ring, but they have strain,
and that strain is called
transannular,
across the ring.
And you can easily see why it
is.
There's a view of a model of
cyclohexane, at the top,
and below is cyclooctane.
Now of course you'd -- Baeyer
thought it would be strained
because you'd have to bend the
bonds out.
But Sachse said you don't have
to bend the bonds out,
all you have to do is pucker
it.
Right?
But if you start puckering too
much, opposite sides will run
into one another.
And you can really see this if
you look at space-filling models
of these.
Here, the repulsion between
those two that are across the
ring, you can see the hydrogens
really crunch into one another.
So these intermediate sized
rings suffer from transannular
strain.
So you can see this by
comparing heats of formation.
Which remember -- how do you --
what experiment do you do to
measure heats of formation?
What actually would you do when
you went into lab?
You have these substances.
What do you do with them in
lab, in order to measure their
heat of formation?
Student: Calorimetry.
Prof: You'd burn them.
Right?
What you actually measure is
the heat of combustion,
right?
But then if you also know -- if
somebody out there has for you
measured the heat of combustion
of graphite,
and the heat of combustion of
hydrogen,
then you have the numbers that
enable you to work up your data
and find out what the heat of
formation of your substance was.
Right?
So now this book,
in Appendix III of this book,
has average bond energies.
And this is what Andrew wanted.
Right?
He wanted to be able to start
with the atoms,
add up all the bonds,
and get the energy.
And, in fact,
here is a table that purports
to do that;
that says that these are
energies you can add up to get
what the heat of atomization
would be.
And you'll notice that it makes
a little distinction among
carbon-carbon bonds,
gives different values for
double and triple bonds,
than for single.
That's certainly sensible.
And the same for nitrogen.
So the question is,
does this work?
Can one sum up bond energies to
get useful heats of atomization?
So how well can bond energies
predict the heat of atomization,
and where does the heat of
atomization come from?
So again you're going to do
these heats of combustion,
but you're going to need
somebody to measure a new value
for you;
not just the heat of combustion
of graphite and the heat of
combustion of hydrogen gas.
And you'll see what you need
here.
Because we're going to now
compare,
not with graphite and hydrogen
-- which is something you can
have in a bottle --
but we're going to compare with
the atoms,
which you can't have in a
bottle.
Now how are we going to measure
the heat of atomization?
We're going to do it
indirectly, by this line.
Right?
We know the heat of combustion
of our substance,
or we measure it.
We know the heat of combustion
of graphite and hydrogen.
So all we need to know is the
heat of atomization of graphite.
How hard is it to get a carbon
atom out of graphite,
or a hydrogen atom out of H_2?
If we knew that,
then we could figure out that
that's going to be
kilocalories/mol;
that's to get out six carbons
from graphite and twelve
hydrogens from H_2 gas,
in order to make the C_6H_12 of
cyclohexane.
Right?
So if you knew that number,
the , the heat of atomization
of graphite and hydrogen,
then you could add all those
together,
with the proper sign,
and get that it's ,
the heat of atomization of
cyclohexane.
And then you could try to
parlay that into what the bond
strengths are,
in cyclohexane.
So what you need is the heat of
atomization of graphite and the
heat of atomization of hydrogen.
But how can you know the heat
of formation for an atom?
You do it by spectroscopy.
So we've seen things like this
before, a Morse-type curve.
And we know that you have an
X-Y diatomic down in the bottom
there.
And if you -- it takes a
certain amount of energy to get
to X plus Y, to get to the
atoms.
If you knew that energy -- and
that's what we want to know;
how hard is it to break these
apart?
H_2, for example,
into 2 H atoms?
But you notice that you could
do this with light,
and if you knew what the
minimum amount of light is,
to go up -- of course,
it's going to be quantized,
right?
There are going to be given
levels, until you get to the
level where it dissociates.
And then, as you'll remember
from Erwin Meets
Goldilocks,
it's not quantized anymore.
You can have any energies you
want.
So if by spectroscopy you can
see when it changes from being
individual lines,
to being a continuum,
where any energy goes,
then you know what that energy
is.
So you'd know how much energy
it takes to go from the molecule
to the atoms.
So you can do that by
spectroscopy.
And in the case of a hydrogen
molecule, it turns out to 104.2.
But from that you get two
hydrogen atoms.
So it's 52.1,
is the heat of formation from
the gas of a hydrogen atom.
So we know that;
because the heat of formation
of H_2 is defined as zero.
That's the element in its
standard state already.
You can do the same thing with
oxygen and get that it's 59.6 to
make an oxygen.
But how do you do carbon?
Because the standard state of
carbon is not C_2.
Right?
And indeed you can't buy C_2 in
a bottle to do the experiment
either.
But what you can get in a
bottle is CO,
carbon monoxide.
So if you did the experiment on
CO, you'd find out that that
number is 257.3.
And now you have what you need;
because that's the difference
between CO and a C atom plus an
O atom.
But you know where CO is,
compared to graphite and
oxygen,
by burning CO,
and you know where oxygen is,
relative to oxygen in its
standard state,
because we just did it with
O_2.
Right?
So there's burning graphite is
26.4.
Graphite to a single oxygen
atom is that heat of formation
of the oxygen atom.
So all we need to have is that
difference, and we know what the
heat of formation of carbon is.
It's going to be 171.3. Okay?
So we're able to do it by doing
spectroscopy on CO.
But this was done -- people got
the number 171.3,
but then they began to worry.
And there were two Nobel
Laureates,
plus Edward Teller -- who was
big in the atomic energy
community in the United States,
you may have heard of him -- so
big time physicists who
absolutely disagreed with 171.3.
Because what they said was that
the spectroscopy was misleading,
that actually it was giving one
of --
the light that was going in was
giving one of the atoms,
not in its normal state,
its low energy state,
but in a higher state.
So the number that you
predicted, that you measured is
171.3, was not to a normal
carbon atom, but to an excited
carbon atom.
Right?
So that the true energy of a
carbon atom would be lower than
that.
And so they thought -- one set
of them thought it would be 141
kilocalories/mol,
and another thought it would be
125.
So these numbers are all very
precise.
You can measure these positions
of spectral lines very
accurately, but you don't know
how to interpret it.
It could be way off,
by twenty or almost fifty
kilocalories/mol.
So you need some other way of
doing this.
And for many years I've brought
in a guest lecturer to explain
how he did it.
But unfortunately he died a
year and a half ago.
So I'll have to tell you what
he would have told you,
but we'll wait until next time
for that.